hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
and on John Humphrey cuz he finally
didn't do the impression I was kinda
hoping yeah you would do it don't worry
I thought about it she did we're gonna
watch the second Hobson shot [ __ ] here
we go let's just go right into this bad
boy now shall we don't waste any time
before we get fast three minutes and 37
seconds that's a [ __ ] gonna be five
trailers for the trailer before the yeah
nice
[Music]
I love this song got vixen
that's a curvy man nice hey a right how
the mirrors
[Music]
nice eyes uh yeah whoa that's gonna be a
cool fight damn Wow
oh yes this is good great
[Applause]
Oh
oh yeah like Mad Max right there yeah
there's the Shyam money shot here
super there we go there we go yeah
best rhythm so far this year david
leitch man that guy knows what he's up
to
step out of the way this does look
enormous in size and skill down listen
before we talk more about this I want to
say thank you to everybody startups that
we do 30 second reaction reviews are any
film TV show and or trailer it's the
third umbrella it's you the whole reel
rejects operation with patreon included
you can post your own reactions on there
as well the whole thing is free to
download free to use you know what let's
just do a star dose reaction right now
let's insert this into video John we
literally just saw the Hobbes and Shaw
trailer I am in love with this we're
gonna see Hobbes his family like not
just this daughter but seed some of his
like Hawaiian roots there which i think
is so cool this is just the definition
of the kind of ridiculousness I love so
much this is just them comparing dick
sizes the whole movie I'm just throwing
the entire action movie kitchen sink at
it anyway
yeah not mentioned in there Vanessa
Kirby I mean she's doing way more than
me oh yeah actually take in some ass
here yeah and I love the way that
they've so heavily infused family into
this even though that the fast family is
no way involved you know Shaw's family
is growing here and Hobbs is like a fire
come in and become warriors and like
help fight you know how at the Aquaman
premiere Jason Momoa and the haka yeah
I'm kind of hoping that Dwayne Johnson
does something similar for the premiere
of this movie the frontiers so it
expected yeah
yeah yeah this trailer went entirely
this trailer felt like two trailers and
it went off-road halfway through when
they go back home and I was sitting here
fascinated because yeah this looks like
the most ridiculous crazy fun action
movie and there are so many different
scenes and settings that I'm sitting
here wondering have we seen something
out of like every chunk of the movie or
is this just going to be such a long
crazy film that I hope this movie is 2
hours and 45 minutes I will gladly sit
through it machismo the chemistry
between Johnson and Jason Statham just
looks so damn funny I love the setup of
that opening fight that they had here
where there's choosing a door and
they're going there's like looking at
each other the whole time as they're
fighting it's literally like I just said
they're just comparing dick sizes the
whole movie yeah there's always in
competition and I love I just loved that
element too because they seemed like
they're the comedy here looks like it's
gonna be the funniest fast and furious
film that's ever been made it's like in
tune it's akin it's within spirit of The
Fast and Furious franchise of what it's
evolved into in terms of how and just
batshit insane it is but it still does
have that david leitch touch to it in
terms of the way the FICO Rockets it's
like yeah sure it's not the grounded
David Lee don't we like but I really
feel his perception here of okay what
can I bring to the table with my style
and infuse it with Fast and Furious and
I really feel like we're getting that
blend yeah I mean it looks like the
action is gonna be super hard-hitting
and you know pretty lively you know and
it doesn't seem unintentionally funny it
seems like it's incredibly self-aware
yeah yourself of being like a black
Superman you know yeah it seems like
they've completely liked The Fast and
the Furious movies get kind of silly and
there are times when they're knowing
about that but I feel like at the core
they want to take something very
seriously whether it's the family aspect
or what but this movie doesn't seem like
it's beholden to the same we're taking
something seriously core so yeah this
looks like it's just gonna be a
balls-to-the-wall action extravaganza
like because like I love the a-team
movie
so I cannot scoff at this because you
know it's the exact theory it's a kind
of thing it's like let's just get as
crazy as possible and have a great time
doing the only thing we're missing for
refresh appears films are reddening
shots of girls in bikinis I know
nobody's like fixing her like leaning
under erisa Gonzales bikini shot man and
man let's sexualize all these women sure
I could just go to her Instagram but I
want to see it in movie or The Rock's
movie mom yeah what about her sure that
they live in a place where there's a lot
of swimwear yeah we're gonna see how
much of happening guys that's for sure
yeah yeah all right guys well before we
wrap this video up I want to give a page
from the day shout out to Taylor Bentley
Taylor basically I've mentioned this a
couple times now last I heard from him
months ago he's just he pledged to her
patreon page he landed himself a hot
girlfriend I haven't heard from him
since
my best guess it's probably Hobbes and
Shaw and and Bentley he's going around
the world kicking ass sleeping with
hot-ass spies doing whatever he can to
just impress that one chica he's got
with him and Taylor keep it up dude
because if you got to be an action hero
to impress a girl you're clipping every
guy's dream I am going lower how badass
you are all the time I'm happy for you
Taylor I'm really happy for you as long
as your card is on file and you don't
notice under wells-fargo banking that
you have been getting charged monthly on
our patreon page I'm okay well whatever
you're doing buddy
enjoy life hopefully I never hear back
from you and that you just stay pledged
indefinitely forever
just drain all of your funding into our
account cuz what do you need before you
got a hot girlfriend now subscribe to
the reject nation click that
notification Bell and hey why don't you
go ahead and check the styling start us
at see you guys